I have spent enough years with Oni to
know the truth once this is over after
all we have done they will order you to
kill us both
the launch of halo 5 is only a week away
but with all the conflicting reports
about the allegiance of the Master Chief
the jury is still very much out on
whether or not you can be trusted this
time well to hear where the public
opinion lies we spoke to a number of
Halo fans to find out what they think
about the loyalties of Master Chief is
he the hero wheel rupiah's or as he
turned evil and gone rogue well let's
hear from the fans
do I think the master chief is dead I
don't think I think if he was to be out
of a storyline thinking more retire than
by everything that's happened and then
suddenly he's just dead we get no
account of it we've got no other
information he's just dead so I can't
really see it personally think he's just
too much important character to be dead
plus you don't send a massive team of
Spartans after summer stick
I think we can definitely be trusted it
seems like he probably knows and has a
plan of what to do whatever he's trying
to do that we don't always doing yet
ultimately he's a Spartan who has only
ever known one thing to save humanity
he's out there to safely but he's a
soldier and he's just always got
everyone else's intentions in mind so
someone like that doesn't suddenly
switch he saved humanity every time if
he wasn't be someone to be trusted why
wouldn't he have betrayed all light turn
his back away from humanity in the past
I feel like he does have a plan we may
not know it and it he probably is
keeping it from us for her and safety
like there are a lot of times in his war
situations ministry situations in the
past where he's had to make very
difficult decisions that the human race
wouldn't agree with but is kind of got
to be done
now a lot of people are thinking about
him being corrupted because of the power
that he's had I don't think he is going
back from from the start of halo what
he's been through an accomplished and
achieved and never been corrupted I
don't I don't think now now is the time
for him to be corrupted so I think he
can still hold the power I think that
he's still you know just himself for him
using his power to corrupt in what would
he you know what would he do it's not
like he owns an m by he's just a single
soldier so I don't think power
corrupting him would he wouldn't gain
anything promise
I think massive motivations are
something along the lines of a twist
that we that we don't expect and that he
doesn't trust lock and locks got
something planned and he's going with
the whole he's not obeying his orders
let me go in and change it fireteam
Osiris the light is green Martians like
you can't see what's about to happen and
I think he thinks lock is going to sort
to take over to what he's built and
obviously he doesn't want that to happen
Cortana was his only ever like his own
he's only like true friend at the end of
halo 4 see she's gone but it might well
be one of those things where she's not
actually gone he could be trying to
pursue her and they're kind of in the
hope that's all no restoring her I'm
getting her back I want you did it
just like you always do he's a legend
way it sounds terribly one like my
childhood icons of everything through
gaming and you kind of just gotta side
with him he's just like how can you not
just like it's like a six foot five
beast has gone through so much just
jumped off of meteors he's destroyed
halo rings like the more level in Halo
one exploding the pillar of autumn he's
gone through so much you can't just not
like appreciate and value him you know
how expensive this curious son tell that
to the government
I think that the humanity would find a
way to survive about him but it's hard
because he has been there for so long
and we don't know what it's like without
him but I think they'd find a way to
survive without him I think given what
he'd done through the events pilot 1 2 3
and 4 and now there are lot of Spartans
who are equally very capable you look at
locks team you look at what they can do
they would probably be honest or take on
you know some of the some of things
others on a threat to come his way most
eat almost sort of laid the foundations
or then to get it off like survival
narrow mission I don't think it's
possible i think as anyone else like him
that could be as good as Master Chief so
I personally think I don't think the
human race would they're due to all that
into your hist
well public opinion is unanimous Master
Chief lives and it looks as though their
trust in him is still very high
ultimately though all that really
matters is that you make up your own
mind hero or rogue what is certain is
that the master chief will once again be
the center of the story in halo 5
Guardians when it launches just a few
days 117 band down this is your one
chance to come home